you're walking down the street in
chinatown
you don't come here too often it can be
a bit touristy but today the streets are
quiet peaceful something in the store
window next to catches your eye
it's one of those
waving cat figurines you usually see
them next to the cash register at your
favorite chinese restaurant
you always thought it was a kind of
kitschy way of saying goodbye to
customers but you're not sure what are
these cats and where do they come from
what do they mean
[Music]
before we continue here's a quick word
from our sponsor and that sponsor is
atlas vpn we all like the internet right
with the internet we can learn new
things shop online and chat with friends
all over the world but the modern
internet isn't always safe and that's
where atlas vpn comes in atlas vpn
protects your internet travel which
means your data will be protected from
invasive tracking snooping and the
dangers of public wi-fi an atlas vpn
does even more than just protect your
data
using its data breach monitor it will
notify you when any personal information
has been compromised
enjoy amazingly fast speeds and protect
an unlimited number of devices
and it even helps you get the best deals
when shopping online but here's my
favorite part
so let's say like me you want to watch
top gear on netflix but you live in
america where top gear and many other
television shows and movies aren't
available well no problem just load up
atlas vpn scroll down pick the uk and
boom a whole new world of tv shows and
movies are available to you right now
atlas vpn is running a huge discount it
means you can get a three-year
subscription for just 183 a month with a
30-day money-back guarantee time is
running out so click the special link in
the description and get access to atlas
vpn's special deal with 82 percent off
thank you again to atlas vpn for
sponsoring this video
so first things first these cats aren't
chinese they're japanese
they are called maneki neko meaning
beckoning cats also the cat isn't waving
at all
this gesture which in america means go
away or shoe is actually a come here
motion in japan
but with this stylized way the cats make
the gesture it looks like waving to us
these beckoning cats have been bringing
good fortune in japan for centuries
but where how and why did they come to
be
ask 10 different shop owners in tokyo
where the cats come from and you'll
likely get 10 different answers
as with most folkloric traditions the
origins of the maneki neko are somewhat
mysterious
there are two stories legends really
that pull the most weight regarding the
origins of the lucky cat
the first story comes from the kotokuji
temple a buddhist temple in tokyo the
story goes that long ago this particular
temple was in dire straits
the abbot running the temple destitute
and worrying about the future of his
parish saw a stray cat on the road and
invited it in for food
from then on the cat lived at the temple
elsewhere the local daimyo or feudal
lord li naotaka was falcon hunting with
his samurai when it began to rain
now taka having been separated from the
group was looking for shelter and saw
the cat beckoning him to the temple he
started towards the cat and as he did
a bolt of lightning struck the ground
where he had been standing the daimyo
thankful that the cat had saved his life
asked the temple monk if there was a way
to repay him and his cat the monk told
naotaka of the trouble the temple was in
and so the daimyo brought the godokuji
temple under his family's patronage
returning the temple to its former glory
if you visit the temple today you will
be met with hundreds of cat statues
honoring the first maneki neko
now this is one of those stories you
can't verify one way or the other
the temple godokuji
is real and the daimyo li nautaka was
also a real person he was the daimyo
over omi in the early 17th century which
is now the shiga prefecture now the
shiga prefecture isn't particularly
close to the kudokuji temple but you
know perhaps he was visiting the problem
is that i couldn't find any evidence of
this story from the time it was supposed
to have happened instead it seems the
tale popped up sometime in the 19th
century 200 years after the daimyo's
death
another similar story comes from the
emado shrine also in tokyo
this story tells of an old widow who is
visited in a dream by the spirit of one
of her old cats it tells her to make
figurines of him and sell them if she
does so good fortune will come upon her
the widow agreed and started making
figurines and sold them at the emado
shrine gate they became very popular and
made her very rich in 1852 around the
time this story was supposedly taking
place the great printmaker utagawa
hiroshige made this woodblock print
showing a marketplace and here on the
left we see a merchant selling maneki
neko kat figurines this is the oldest
image of the maneki neko we have
so the manikineko probably originated in
the 18th or 19th century in japan around
tokyo or it may have originated in
different places at different times
after all cats have held an important
place in japanese culture for centuries
like the nekomata a mythological cat
with two tales that eats people or the
old japanese proverb if you kill a cat
it will haunt your family for seven
generations which indicates the belief
that cats have much longer lives than
humans
this of course reminds us of the western
folklore that says cats have nine lives
and that points to the more general
truth that cats are seen as magical
creatures all across the world i mean
think of ancient egypt
okay so back to the cat this specific
cat that is there are three main parts
of the cat that matter we already
discussed the gesture and how the wave
is actually a come hither motion there
is some discussion about the meaning
depending on which side the wave is on
though it's said that the right paw
attracts money and good fortune and the
left paw attracts business and customers
i'm unsure how many people observe this
distinction though or how widespread it
is
next we have the caller and bib this is
there to show the domesticity and
reverence for the cat
the caller will often have bells on it
but will sometimes have an old japanese
coin
though most commonly the coin is held by
the cat like in this example the coin is
there to represent wealth
lastly the color the traditional design
is in white with red and gold accents
white being the color of the porcelain
it's traditionally made of but other
colors exist too each representing a
different thing
gold represents prosperity and wealth
pink represents luck in love and romance
and blue represents protection and
safety so next time you're in chinatown
and see one of these cats beckoning you
into a store why not pop in and have a
look around to honor our feline friends
thanks a lot for watching and thanks
again to atlas vpn for sponsoring this
video follow the link below and protect
your internet privacy for just 183 a
month and if you want to support the
channel consider supporting me on
patreon
bye
[Music]